foreign
[Music]
Parr and special guest Andrew Wilkinson
come on out you guys
[Applause]
[Music]
all right
so we're uh we are backstage and we saw
like all the bands that have played here
it's like Franz Ferdinand and like the
killers and all these cool things and
I heard the sound guys first of all
sound guys I want to apologize I heard
them talking before this and they're
like what the [__] is this
like there's like is this like a rich
guy's birthday party what is this I
think they thought it was a graduation
happening so sound guys sorry but it is
what it is you always wanted to be a
star you wanted to walk out to a
sold-out venue and uh I guess this was
it's one way to do it that's one way to
do it so sound guy it's gonna be the
lamest thing you're gonna see this week
but maybe you'll learn something I don't
know uh
but this is awesome what do you think
working [__] you sound guys this is
working come on guys I can tell who the
real podcasters are sure so so we did
this huge event in Vancouver we had like
1200 people in this massive theater and
Sam sneaks out on the stage and I'm like
what are you doing and he's he's peering
around the corner taking photos and he
goes I'm posting this on Facebook and I
was like who the [__] uses Facebook
that's so weird and he goes all the
people I went to high school with
uh and so we wanted to start off by
saying we are laughing backstage I and
we were like right before we came on
we're like we got to talk about Nick
Gray
does anyone here has anyone here met
Nick Ray that was the guy that was just
talking
I just met him for the first time last
night he is I don't know if he's the
most interesting man in the world but
he's like the most interesting man in
Texas for sure I'll give him that I feel
like on this show we always talk about
billionaires and there's a lot of money
billionaires but Nick is a friend
billionaire yeah a lot last night so we
hosted a dinner last night with like I
don't know 15 people and Sam had set it
all up it was gonna be perfect
he had this like high-end restaurant
table for 14 the time was locked in we
got reminders we show up it's supposed
to be beautiful uh you know just a first
class dinner everything was taken care
of
and we get there
and immediately the plan was blown up it
was raining outside raining like crazy
and our seat was like half outside yeah
so we weren't going to be able to do it
immediately Nick Gray improvises he's
like hold on
you six to the bar and then he sprinted
because I pulled up I saw him running
and I was like Nick Gray where you going
and he was like
I'm scoping out a venue and he I don't
know where he went he runs into this
place and he's like hey is this a event
space soaking wet yeah and the women
look at each other and they're like what
and he goes what's the name of this
place and they go it's called Miss
Kitty's and he's like are you guys in
event space What do you do he goes we
wax women oh
I got 15 dudes outside or not
but he did he found us this like like
abandoned Shack almost this amazing
place and he he got us it was really
like a shed it was an abandoned shed but
it was like I don't know it was perfect
it was exactly what we did it was
outside the rain we were all in there
was quiet we could talk and um and he
hosts this thing so what Nick does is he
has this book called I think the
two-hour cocktail party and he's
basically perfected the art of a
two-hour party and I got to see it
firsthand he takes out his harmonica to
like get everyone's attention and then
he uh he has this way of getting
everybody to open up to talk to sit in
the right places do the right things
and it was incredible the best part
though was
he saved your he saved you so so Nick is
looking around and he walks up to me he
goes hey are you all good everything
good uh and I say okay I want to go to
the shed I'm excited I'm a little bit
cold though is it gonna be uh is it
gonna be heated and he goes hold on I'll
be right back and he runs outside and
like Sam said it's like pouring rain I
don't know if you guys witnessed this
yesterday but it was insane he comes
back he's soaking wet he looks like that
scene in Glenn Gary Glenn Ross when the
guy's like at the doorstep and he brings
me this sweatshirt which he had paid
like 70 dollars for that's who Nick Gray
is and the reason we're bringing this up
is not because we like him
to be clear we like him to be clear we
like him but that's not why we're
bringing this up but on our pod my first
million uh and by the way is everyone
here is anyone who doesn't listen to MFM
here
who's here for the graduation yeah okay
and who here actually listens to us
regularly
all right let's get up and so we bring
up all these like weird businesses that
a lot of people haven't
um heard about and this one is probably
the weirdest one he he told me he was
going to write this book about a
cocktail party I thought it was a
horrible idea and so far he sold 11 000
copies of this book which is insane and
he um and so we have this dinner and we
meet all these interesting people at
this like 14 person dinner I think we
had a guy there who sold a company that
sold dog supplements which is like the
greatest business ever because who knows
if it works right like you have no idea
he sold his company for 650 million
dollars it was insane and he was telling
us a story about this we had another guy
who sells also dog related dog ramps so
like so you're old or small dog can like
go up on the couch and he does 18
million a year in sales there was
another guy there that has a website
that is like a Marketplace so you can
rent a tractor and it's killing it we
had a a person who has a bunch of owns a
bunch of car washes that does tens of
millions in profit what else we have
anything else that was weird it was
great it was crazy it was different than
San Francisco if you go to San Francisco
or New York you get one type of
entrepreneur you get the AI crypto you
get that in SF in New York you get
something else and in Austin you get
mustache hat tail and like I sell
tractors online or I'll sell your dog
some vitamins you know what you get a
different type of entrepreneur but in
the I bet in the crowd right now we
gotta have some interesting businesses
yeah who who here has a business let's
get it get a sense of here so keep your
hand up if you own a business and if you
do over 100 raise them high raise them
up if you do over a hundred thousand
dollars keep it up if you do five
hundred thousand keep it up uh one
million
five million
okay we got a few twenty twenty million
anybody no okay back to five no no no we
got them over here okay 20 million 20
million and a couple of we got one over
here okay two here one in the back any
of those any of them profitable
okay all right okay Nick we want to talk
to these guys I want to know what their
businesses are put their hands up hand
is up I'm coming over here all right
stand up please let's hear from you
what's your name and what's your
business Kelsey Larrick 365 Holdings or
an e-commerce roll up sorry can you say
that one more time 306 Mission please
365 Holdings we roll up e-commerce
businesses I want to be Andrew Wilkinson
when I grow up
[Music]
that you don't trust me he's blushing up
here it's very sad
who's the guy next to you uh Justin
Turner attraction Capital our we have a
business that sells equipment to fire
departments what do you mean
I love the way you said all that but I'm
gonna can I just try being you for a
second
Sean Puri Puri dad of dad of the house
change diapers like you just said
just stepping but with such like
you're probably right about me
we sell like 37 million dollars worth of
equipment that fire departments use and
firemen use every day like yeah houses
nozzles uniforms uniforms and why is
Okay so and what about competition is it
just like you're the only one in town
there's only one place to buy them or do
you have a moat of some kind we have
exclusive distribution uh relationships
in nine of the western states in the US
how much profit on 37 million in Revenue
uh it's about 10 margin does it feel
uncomfortable when I ask you these
questions should I ask like what do you
like naked what was it like when you
lost your virginity there's only one way
to find out
this data is wrong every freaking time
have you heard of HubSpot
HubSpot is a CRM platform where
everything is fully integrated well I
can see the client's whole history calls
support tickets emails and here's a test
from three days ago I totally missed
HubSpot grow better
um all right what else and who else
who's got a weirder story than that
anybody got a weirder story yeah put
your hand up if you've got a really
weird business okay maybe it was like
weird yes yeah yeah hold on one sec
please
okay so this is a paper Koozie but I own
a 40 000 square foot print wear shop
warehouse and we print real Koozies so
like it's really Niche and it's really
random not these small boy cruises how
long you've been running your business
for
um I've been in business for eight years
but we do a lot of different types of
printing
um did you become a millionaire selling
beer koozies that was my first largest
e-com store that I created yeah sewing
Koozies because I'm from the Midwest and
we drink a lot of beer and that's you
look like you're from the Midwest yeah
anyone else have a really really weird
business like dog ramp level weird
business tell them to let the freak flag
fly
guy with the Austin stash there it is
the capital v-neck shirt you just grow
those when you fly in as soon as you
cross the the border the mustache just
pops up we make custom dog treats for
Hospitality businesses so like when the
Ritz Carlton uh has guests come with
dogs we provide the dog treats that they
give to their guests and why wouldn't
they just use number normal dog treats
just because ours have their branding on
them oh very smart how big is that
um we started 10 months ago and we've
grown it to half a million in 10 months
at run right wow that's all right this
is cool we're gonna we're gonna hear
more businesses because a little bit
later we're gonna do like a shark tanky
type of thing with a bunch of uh a bunch
of pitches yeah you're we could put we
could put the lights down two times okay
there we go
um so the cool part about like doing
this stuff is we get to meet all these
interesting people who are succeeding
and some are failing which is actually
just or more interesting
um but speaking of a big success Andrew
over here took his company I thought
you're pointing at me no
uh Andrew over here just took his
company public it's called tiny it's not
that tiny
yeah that should be the tagline it's not
and you were telling he was telling us a
story that we had not heard about almost
selling the company
like six this was a backstage story can
we tell it I think we could yeah we can
we can tell it so there's really two
stories so one by the way if you don't
know I I gotta do the intro uh Andrew
started this thing called meta lab it
was an agency that made a bunch of um
Tech stuff for big companies using the
profits from that company he then
started buying and investing in other
companies which that whole company that
hold company was or holdco was called uh
tiny he recently took it public last
week it's now trading at 850 million
Canadian dollars which is only like 600
million bucks in real money uh no but it
was it's a huge success but it all
started because he had this agency
called meta lab where he was um you know
like I said doing stuff for tech people
but you were saying earlier that how
that was like the foundation for the
success of everything else but you it
you almost did something crazy early on
yeah so I almost wasn't sitting wouldn't
be sitting here so uh we were sitting at
dinner the other night and talking about
this and uh there's two stories so one
uh I got very excited when you know you
when you have a business you always know
how much it sucks how hard it is to run
and you always admire other people's
businesses and so I always wanted like a
SAS business a sexy business and so I
started one I started this productivity
uh business called flow it was like
Asana except we didn't raise any money
and we uh we had a great product but it
just didn't go anywhere like uh task
management task management which is one
of the hardest things one of the hardest
businesses in the world and uh I got so
excited about it at one point that I I
was up at like 11 o'clock at night I was
feeling all manic I'd probably had a
couple beers and I sent this email the
entire staff and I said guys we're
shutting metal lab down we're going all
in on Flow and Chris my business partner
who's here somewhere where's Chris Chris
over there uh Chris was the CFO at the
time and he looked at the numbers he was
like we will be out of business three
months how big was Flo was doing like
300K of Revenue 2 million or something
like that and so because when you when
when you were two million maybe two
million in Revenue versus 300 000 300K
or something I was just like moment of
insanity and Chris went around to all
the employees quietly and was like
please don't leave please don't leave
we'll be bankrupt in like a week and
save the day and then the second story
was uh Chris and I we you know running
an agency he's really stressful and we
got this offer for the business to sell
it for 15 million this is about eight or
nine years ago almost 10 years ago and
fifteen one five fifteen one five and uh
we actually went through the whole
process you know spent four months going
back and forth with this private Equity
Firm we signed the documents you know my
lawyer calls me in quivering hand I
signed signed the documents and the wire
is supposed to come in the next day and
so I wake up I go to my local bank
branch I go to the ATM and I look at the
balance my balance is the same and I
think okay it's probably going to come
in later so I check later nothing next
day nothing next day nothing I call the
guide the private Equity Firm and he
goes hey man I'm really sorry but we
weren't able to finish closing our fund
so the deal is not done so I legally
sold the business and if the wire had
come in I would my business would be
worth maybe nothing at this point
because this was the entire foundation
of the business and we would be we would
be tiny so we almost lost it all what do
you think it's worth now meta lab I
don't know hundreds of Millions for sure
but I don't know it all could have just
one decision actually you made the
decision and it's
and it was anxiety right it's Panic
every I'm sure every one of you that
runs a business everyone knows how
miserable it is inside right I've you
talk to people you look at them on the
outside you go they're an amazing
operator they have a great business but
on the inside there's a great quote by
Brent be sure he goes every business is
a slow motion Knife Fight right like you
just wake up in the morning you're
sweating and you're fighting you're
trying to survive right and we felt that
way and we pushed through and it was
okay but we almost gave in did you
before you sold the hustle it's a
HubSpot
did you ever
almost said did you come close to
selling before that so when I was
running the company I was miserable most
every time so if you go on like Facebook
or Instagram look at my pictures from
like 2017 and 18 I was lumpy I was like
pretty fat uh and I was like because I
was eating all the time to like make
myself feel better so I was miserable
most the time and then this one company
emailed me
to uh they showed interest in buying and
so I fly all the way out to New York and
I start talking to them and I get in
their office and like it's empty and I'm
like where is everyone and they're like
oh they're doing stuff and they take me
to a an office to have the meeting and I
look in the windows of each office and
they're in a every employee is in a
sexual harassment seminar because the
CMO had just like you know gone off the
rails and did a bunch of bad [__]
um and so they get me in a room they
like send me a term sheet and they're
like well buy your company for 10
million dollars but it's going to be all
in stock and I was like well show me the
financials and like let me see what's
going on with your business and I got a
peek in it and the company was vice vice
media which means that deal I was so
close to taking it it would be worth
zero I'd probably be in debt because
advice like the valuation has just
plummeted and so I almost took that
because I was so like desperate to get
out sexual harassment seminar almost
saved you he did yeah yeah you're a
survivor
[Music]